your relationship to the present moment
determines how the future evolves what
we call Future which by the way never
arrives the realization that all you
ever have all that you can ever
experience is intrinsically linked with
the present moment Inseparable from the
present your entire life unfolds in and
as the present moment that what ever is
when the past happened it was the
present moment couldn't happen anywhere
else and when you remember the past you
remember it in the present moment when
the future comes it won't be tomorrow
anymore it will be the now there was a a
British pup in London they had a sign on
the bar that says free beer tomorrow and
of course Tomorrow Never Comes so the
side it's always
true hey it's EV Carmichael and I make
these videos because I need them because
I want to wake up every single day and
get pushed by somebody who's doing a lot
more more than me and in watching their
videos it inspires me to be bolder to
have more courage and go chase down the
life of my dreams and I hope it does the
same for you so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only at C tole
enjoy he that knows how to walk
interiorly and to make but little
account of things
exteriorly does not look for places nor
wait for season to perform exercises of
devotion the man of interior life soon
recollects himself because he never
wholly poures forth himself upon
exterior
things exterior labor is no Prejudice to
him nor any employment necessary for the
time but as things happen so he
accommodate himself to
them let's look at those two sentences
very
important the man the P the human being
of interior life soon recollects himself
because he never wholly pours himself
forth upon exterior things a lovely way
of putting it the interior man again we
had that before it means it points to
the who you are at the level of
awareness the unconditioned being the
Timeless in you the essence of who you
are the interior
being soon recollects himself never
really you never the interior man never
completely loses himself in the in the
external he he or she soon recollects
himself because you he never holy I'll
just put it into slightly more modern
English he never wholly pours force
himself upon exterior things to pour
yourself into exterior things to
completely lose yourself in exterior
Things You observe it all the time when
you just before you see it in yourself
look at other humans around you how they
lose themsel all that the slightest
challenge comes in the form of
an
unexpected
setback uh something going wrong here or
there some difficult situation a person
not not doing what I expect them to do
whatever it is how
quickly people pour themselves into
exterior things and so this thing
suddenly becomes of absolute importance
that that's what it means pouring
yourself out out into
things which ultimately of course you
pour yourself into your
thoughts every thought that
arises takes complete possession of you
you pour all your attention into
that so you a continuously loss a
continuous
loss
amazing you can see it in others let
just wait people around you how what
they do when challenges
come okay you've done that now you've
recognized in others the next step
is oh you can you recognize in yourself
do you do that also when wait for the
next challenge do you completely does it
completely draw you out of
yourself and when it does don't beat
yourself up but even just noticing that
that's what's happening happening is a
huge gain in
Consciousness so don't you don't beat
yourself up and say oh I can't do no
just just notice it your any pattern you
notice in yourself means there is some
Consciousness there's awareness there
it's when you don't know it that it
you're completely trapped in it and if
you don't know it there's not much you
can do except after the challenge has
passed perhaps you can look back and say
oh I completely lost it there
again and when that so awareness comes
after The Challenge which is even which
is still better than no awareness at
all and because if there's no awareness
at all even the most unconscious
reaction you will justify afterwards to
yourself and to others the ego is good
at finding excuses and just
justifications the most absurd
justifications will do it's an automatic
defense mechanism of the ego free will
ultimately does not come in until
there's some awareness in you that's
where Free Will comes from until you
have some
awareness uh you are run by the
conditioning of your mind and so you
have no choice the element of choice
comes in when you become aware for
example of your the thoughts that go
through your head and you might realize
suddenly and for some people that's the
first time they awaken spiritually when
they realize that for years they've had
a voice in their head talking to them
which could be a monologue it could be a
dialogue you could have a conversation
with yourself you can you can beat
yourself up and say why why you're no
good enough aren't you and then the Part
of Yourself well well I'm doing my best
I'm just I can't I can't do it I'm not
I'm not good enough
the voice in the head for some people
the spiritual awakening comes when they
become aware that there's a voice in the
head and there's the awareness right and
the moment there awareness you might
even be able to choose to let go of a
certain thought a repetitive thought
that you don't need anymore that you
don't want anymore and then you you
surrender it or you breathe it out you
don't need it you an emotion sometimes
people in the grip of strong emotions
but if there's a little of awareness
there if let's say it's anger you
suddenly anger arises but in the
background you're aware that there's
emotion of anger so there's a small
element of choices come in do you want
to then attack this person if there's
awareness you can observe the anger but
may may long may no longer need to act
it out I'm not talking about suppressing
but
recognizing the more awareness you have
or presence the more choice there's in
your life and then it's only then that
you actually become truly intelligent
because this awareness is not an IQ
thing the aw you can have I've met
highly intelligent people with one or
two or three
phds academics and others were
completely uncons completely unaware
still just completely in their minds and
and people
in their personal lives often very
dysfunctional personal lives uh so it's
not to be equated with intelligence this
awareness to take your responsibility
for what is it that you can take
responsibility for
primarily it's taking responsibility for
your State of
Consciousness
which
determines what kind of world you
create you because you are
Humanity humanity is an abstract concept
doesn't exist humanity is the human
being you are Humanity so for
Humanity to take responsibility you need
to take primarily responsibility for
your State of Consciousness because only
a diseased or dysfunctional State of
Consciousness produces a diseased and
dysfunctional world out
there by world I mean the human-made
world that is has been imposed on the
what's already there the planet which is
potentially of course a
paradise the
planet pristine unbelievable
Jewel a being of great
intelligence we are not separate from
it but the being is going through a
transitional process and every
transitional process is critical it may
or may not work in which case the being
will go go some other way but
the your State of Consciousness
determines what kind of world you create
what kind of action you take and what
consequences your actions
have so here this is why my main work is
to address the cause of dysfunction
which lies in the human mind mind the
dysfunction of the human mind or as it
is sometimes called in Z the sickness of
the human
mind
so as I see it and I don't think anybody
who reads history can doubt it there is
a
deep-seated dysfunction in humans has
been there for thousands of
years
and if we not if there's no shift in
that then the dysfunction will destroy
us it probably won't destroy the planet
because the planet has enormous
resources but it'll take a while would
take a while for the planet to
recover all you have to do then is
primarily take responsibility for your
State of Consciousness
now
now and this is what the entire teaching
really is about what is What is my State
of Consciousness at this moment am I
generating disturbance am I
generating
negativity am I generating conflict and
suffering for myself and others am I
generating inner pollution am I
polluting my beautiful the beautiful
being that I
am with
continuous
absurd movements of thought
producing negative emotions producing an
entire
entity that is illusory that I call the
me so to take responsibility there needs
to be just of course an Awakening where
you can say okay I will take
responsibility
now some people don't know that there is
even the possibility of taking
responsibility that's why you are so
important anybody who realizes
it this is you are the beginning of
the transformed World also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will will also give you space
to write down what your key takeaways
are and your specific plan of action to
make sure you're getting results if you
want the worksheet designed specifically
for this video absolutely for free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there affirmations are if
they are done rightly can be very
beautiful substitutes for
prayers
um I'm Healed
and whole and at
peace and after that let there be a
space and really the power is in that
space in the space you experience that
you are already
whole the outward form might tell you
something
different I'm holy causing Miracle says
I am Holy for example that's again you
are and so it's simply an
affirmation of how it this is how it
is or if you healing for somebody
else you are either with that
person or that person comes into your
mind you're thinking about that person
and that person may be
ill and then the most powerful healing I
find is to be
to hold the image of that person and
then go deeper into
yourself where the wholeness of Life
lies where nothing is needed nothing is
needs to be added and there you you find
the wholeness also of that person
they're already healed at that deepest
level Beyond form they're already healed
so you go from
form and then into formlessness
happiness of
fulfillment does not depend on any other
humans acceptance of who you are that
would be a deluded thought if you think
you can only be happy if these people
accept and understand you some people
have that with their
parents they so they say my dad my
father they don't understand me at all
it's terrible terrible I'm trying to
explain what I
add of course they they they cannot
understand you it's beyond their
comprehension if you have awakened
spiritually and they
haven't so compassionately accept that
they cannot understand you instead of
trying to explain yourself to them just
be there in a loving way with them when
you meet for Christmas or Thanksgiving
and you hear all the judgments coming at
you from them you should have why don't
you look where it's taken you look at
your sister she married a millionaire
and
you and you are into that weird kind of
meditation stuff that's not getting you
anywhere whatever judgments come and say
okay I know that this is what you think
and feel and I think and feel
differently that's all so you don't not
need to
justify accepting people's limitations
and suddenly realizing whether or not
your father your mother your sister your
brother or anybody else Close to You
accepts you for who you
are is really not you become free of the
need to be accepted but you can
nevertheless have a deeper connection
keep that deeper connection and
connectedness with them I've had this
strange feeling idea in the past few
months um that a certain segment of
humanity is
uh uh losing the ability to think
rationally there's a decrease in whether
I call it IQ or whatever it may be
there's a diminishment of rational
faculty as reflected in many ways on uh
mainstream media social media and so
on uh and another segment of humanity is
actually becoming more aware more aware
more conscious is not drawn into the
regressive phase that some of humanity
may be going through It's Not Unusual
for Humanity to occasionally
collectively regress to a lower State of
Consciousness it has happened uh
whenever a country or Collective has
been taken over
by uh an almost one could say toxic
ideology that has completely taken
possession of millions of people's
minds look at of course n national
socialism in Germany the maist cultural
revolution was quite crazy what happened
in Cambodia under
pport uh totally crazy ideas invaded
millions of people's minds and
uh reduce their ability to to actually
engage in rational thinking and uh it
things that happened for example in MA
China during the cultural revolution
um children reporting on their parents
when they were angry with their parents
all they had to do is go to school and
Report their parents if they had said
something against the government the
parents would be taken away and never
seen again they they went around public
parks in big cities in China tearing out
flowers out of because Beauty was
regarded as Bourgeois you to kill your
your pets your your dogs and cats uh
totally and these are just a few
examples of totally toxic and uh
irrational thoughts taking over people's
minds so that's to some extent I've been
seeing this happening
uh collectively not just in one country
in quite a few Western many Western
countries that uh I'm aware of and uh
but it has not affected everybody uh
some people have managed to remain aware
they have not been one could say
infected by what one could perhaps call
a a a mental virus or mental viruses
that uh um reduce people's ability to
actually see reality reality then gets
distorted through the veil of these
mental viruses that have taken over
people's
minds um this is um uh more serious more
serious pandemic than anything that
happens on the physical level as far as
um uh pandemics are concerned the actual
viruses actually you might I don't know
if you've read
car Yung said that the greatest danger
that Humanity faces is not from any
external Force like natural disasters
or dis diseases or pandemics he said the
greatest danger that Humanity faces is
uh Collective psychosis for someone was
a little bit
hyperactive what's the best way to get a
balance between removing content which
is really
good but then not getting annoyed when
content comes in and you think oh it's
it's
spoiling my piece is there some way to
get a balance be more a listener than a
speaker make that your practice for the
time
being I'm not saying don't say a word
but be more like 80% a
listener than a speaker and that would
for example you can do by asking
questions when you're in rather than
stating your view or whatever it is ask
questions that encourages the other
person to speak more if the other person
speaks more it forces you to listen and
then make the listening into a practice
while the other person is
speaking are you able to let's at any
time to feel your inner body body can
you feel that the hands but but then
seem to lose them quite quickly okay but
but hands you can feel the energy in
your hands the rest of the body is more
difficult yeah yeah okay well it's a
good start it's a start so I suggest
that once you've asked a question while
you
listen you direct your awareness into
the inner feeling of your hands yeah
yeah thank and that keeps it there so
that it doesn't
your mind doesn't take off so you ask a
question what um where are you from how
long have you been with Ard how did you
first discover the the
books um have you been to other R many
questions you can ask and people will be
happy to help you by answering your
questions and they will be happy to help
you by not asking you too many questions
yeah no thank you that that's good yeah
that'll help yeah so and so while you
listen have your attention in the inner
energy field of your hands if if you can
amplify that and have your attention
also in other parts of your body for
example your feet and hand at the same
time that's even better but hands is
fine too so you feel your inner the
aliveness in your hands and from there
you you listen and you know
just give it this will help you prevent
the stream of Mind from taking you over
many people don't are uncomfortable with
themselves they dislike who they are
perhaps they dislike their body how they
look perhaps they
dislike who they are as a person don't
feel they are good enough or are
self-critical a lot
they many people live with negative self
image which of course all consists of
certain types of Mind
activity and that's that's not
pleasant and it may be for some of those
people once they realize that they live
with
a mind pattern
that
continually criticizes them and dis says
negative things about
them they begin to realize that it's a
mind pattern this self
hatred is a mind
pattern and that it's harmful it's not
pleasant and they can go beyond it and
begin to replace it with more negative
thoughts about more positive thoughts
about
themselves and having positive thoughts
about yourself that kind of thing would
perhaps usually be called beginning to
love yourself to feel good about
yourself but it's not it's not easy that
shift from feeling bad about yourself to
feeling good about sometimes it requires
a lot of
convincing I would regard loving
yourself as a perhaps an intermediate
stage in once's
Awakening but the essence of the
awakened
Consciousness is that you go
[Music]
beyond
having a
particular idea in your mind that
represents yourself a a mental self
image that you relate to
because basically it's it's
ego a mental self-image of who you think
this is what I am this is who I
am if you want to learn about not having
a mental
self-image watch your dog or your
cat they don't have an opinion about who
they are they just are who they
are so that removes an enormous amount
of problems from their
lives of course they don't have the Mind
activity that creates a self-image in
their
head they are pre- mind and therefore
their life is far less problematic than
human life you can see how wonderful it
is not to have a self-image you can even
you can look at an ugly dog or an ugly
cat they don't have a problem with
that even an overweight dog or cat they
okay no self-image most of the time
there is a voice in your head that
comments and has opinions and viewpoints
and
interpretations about what's going on in
your life I call that the voice in the
head for most humans that is completely
involuntary they don't even know that
they have a voice in the head that never
stops
talking most of the
time silently in your head at other
times it may even shout something out so
it it wants to be
hurt and so if you walk in the street
you will find most people look fairly
sane they're not talking to themselves
it seems because they're not talking out
aloud but if you listened into
everybody's head you would be amazed of
how
noisy the inside of every human is it's
like a r you know these radio stations
where the the people talk in an excited
voice they go on and
on if you go to foreign country and you
don't know what they're talking about
you might think this must be extremely
important but if you can understand what
they are saying you realize it's it's
completely meaningless it's just
noise so a significant part of what
happens in your mind the the larger part
is actually just Superfluous
noise there's thinking is a wonderful
ability a wonderful tool tool if used
rightly it is an instrument that
causes dysfunction and misery for
Millions on the planet unhappiness for
Millions on a planet if thinking is not
used but if you are used by thought so
when humans say I think in most cases
that's actually not true because they
have no control over their thinking it's
an compulsive and
involuntary and they are so identified
with these thought processes they don't
even know that they are in the grip of
their thought processes because they are
so identified they become their thought
processes so whatever comes into your
head you completely believe in it and
then you yeah that's how it is whenever
you
feel unhappiness this is a generic term
unhappiness in whatever form unhappiness
can arise as
irritation can arise as anger can arise
as
even boredom is a form of
unhappiness
sadness um all kinds of states that are
they don't feel Pleasant they to
unhappiness and usually they are
attributed to life situation something
that's going on in your
life so for example waiting at the
airline counter and of course how often
things don't go well
there uh let's hope they don't drag you
out of the plane but it that could that
could happen
too whenever you feel irritation Rising
anger Rising upset in whatever form ask
yourself is this caused by the
situation or is it caused by what my
mind is telling me about the
situation and in 95% of
cases you will find that the mental
commentary that argues and complains
about something that's going on but
should not be going on but it is but
shouldn't be and the gap between what is
and what the mind says should be or
should not be that Gap is the rising of
unhappiness and
misery or is the Buddha called suffering
a powerful uh transformation can happen
when you and this this is one way of
approaching it which may be helpful to
you uh is not
to
desire
any thing within you to be different
from the way it is
now so that would mean complete
acceptance of whatever it is that you
experience at any given moment at the
moment there are these energies in you
but you don't really want them so there
is a there's a conflict between what you
want and what you have
have now if you approach it in a
different way instead of hang what you
want you perhaps you want Stillness you
want peace you want that deeper sense of
aliveness perhaps that's the yearning
you want to be fully
yourself and what you have is you
perhaps you feel contraction in the body
you feel excessive mind activity you
feel an En
almost semi physical energy field
blocking
you so you have the two you have what
you want and you have what you
have now as a practice I suggest
that you do away with a conflict between
what you have and what you
want and you want what you have
instead which means whatever your inner
reality or outer reality but we're
talking mainly about inner now whatever
your inner reality is right now as it's
always now of course not it's not a big
thing it's only the reality
now accept it it totally this is this is
what is and so bring that acceptance is
a strange thing when you really can say
well that's what is you might as well
accept it because it it is the reality
of this
moment so if you bring that acceptance
to no matter even if it feels not
pleasant if it might be a contraction in
the body or my mind is just so active
Okay let my mind be active bringing
bring the allowing to it and that the
strange thing happens you may find when
you do it you you will already be have a
little bit of space around the condition
that you dislike but now you accept and
so you accept the condition that you
previous ly disliked but now you say
well that's what is and so I allow it to
be and what you then can sense if you're
inside of you a little bit of space
around the condition to not much at
first just a little bit so let's say you
have a contraction here and say that's
what
is and this
acceptance brings space so here is a and
then he have a little bit of that's what
is and
then it may grow a little bit the space
around
it and then you
[Music]
find you become more interested in that
little space around it than in the
condition so you give more attention to
that the spaciousness that around that
comes with the
acceptance of what is and you can sense
that space a bit more and then it what
I'm say is not literally true but I'm
just saying it grows it seems to grow
and then there's a bit more condition is
still the same but it has receded
somewhat it's no longer the center of
your attention you the you more aware of
the space you become the space f so
to to go about wanting to manifest
material abundance in your life is
perhaps not the the right way to go
about
it because you're concentrating on the
outermost layer of
abundance and even if you manage to
manifest abundance on the outer
level it's not going to give you the
true feeling of abundance it's not in
other words it's not going to make you
happy it's not going to fulfill you
except for a few days the new possession
nice and shiny whatever it is and then
you look at it got it now it's
mine and after a few days or a week or
two or give it a
months it wears
off
H it's no longer that fulfilling to be
driving the Ferrari or whatever it is
there's nothing wrong with the Ferrari
but if you're looking to the ferar for
happiness and fulfillment and to get you
give you the feeling of
it's not going to work for that long if
you're just driving it because you enjoy
that experience it's a different matter
manifest abundance From the Inside Out
not from the outside as hoping that you
go find some inner State through
external
things that is a dilemma of many people
who practice
manifesting which of course manifesting
is a
something
that you can
use and it works if it's done
rightly but the Dilemma or the fallacy
is the belief that whatever you manifest
is going to make you happy is to
seek the fullness of life through what
you
manifest through things does the Mind
create create a physical problem to
distract us from emotional
pain it is often the case that emotional
pain that is not
recognized when there's not enough
awareness the emotional pain
exists beneath your level of awareness
and it can come out
as certain kinds of
reactivity in daily
life so you are taken over by reactions
to certain things that trigger that type
of emotional pain that is in you that
you're completely unaware
of and emotional pain that is in total
unawareness can very easily
become a physical symptom it transferred
into the Physical
Realm any kind of
prolonged negative mental
States
which produce
corresponding negative
emotions affect the
functioning of the physical
organism and even research has been done
and on this and been confirmed that
negative States mental emotional states
affect in the long term affect the
physical organism when things go
wrong that's a moment of becoming more
conscious it's every even the smallest
things if you don't react out of the
conditioning the mental emotional
conditioning but be the awareness and
then
oh and You
observe if emotions arise you are there
and you can say oh there's the anxiety
again and then you know that there's
anxiety without calling it
anything this is a huge difference to
know that anxiety is in you anger is in
you right now for example or anxiety
whatever else it may be or some mood
that
suddenly gets a hold of you then you're
suddenly in a bad mood don't talk to me
don't
see I'm grumpy well to say I'm grumpy is
already a little bit step forward
because at least you know that you're
[Music]
grumpy if you're totally CC conscious
the grumpiness is you and you don't even
know that you're grumpy to say don't
talk to me I'm grumpy that's already
means there's a little bit of awareness
there that's
great so there's a huge difference
between
saying I'm angry
and slight I feel angry or there's anger
in me I feel that there's anger in me I
feel angry there's a somewhat a
difference between I am angry because
then you equate identity with the
emotion so it's not I am angry that's a
huge you fallen into a you trap if you
equate emotion with your identity or if
you equate a thought with your identity
or a story in your mind you equate that
with your identity or an opinion which
is thought the world is full of people
who don't know the difference between
their opinion and their identity their
opinion becomes their
identity and then they have lots of
fights with other
people because they are they are totally
confused about who they are they derive
their identity from a set of opinions
politics for example you derive doesn't
mean you cannot have opinions everybody
has opinions but where does your sense
of identity come from does it come from
the opinions or do you realize that you
have certain opinions which may be valid
or not you you on the human level you
have opinions or viewpoints or
perspective mental positions you have
them they are
there
but do you do this give you your sense
of self or if they do
then you're
continuously arguing with other people
making other people into enemies because
when you contradict somebody who equates
opinion with
identity unconsciously they be believe
that you are attack attacking their very
self because there's a confusion about
who they are they don't know who they
are so you you attack the opinion of
somebody who's totally identified with
their opinion and you become their
mortal
enemy they might even try to kill you in
extreme form of unconsciousness do not
be attached to the fruit of Your
[Music]
Action which of course simply
means do don't look to the the goal of
what you want to achieve through
whatever you're doing now give your
complete attention to the doing rather
than where you want to get to through
the
doing and that's again very important
lesson nowadays because most humans
don't know that yet they are always is
one moment ahead they want to get
there you may find in your own life
still a lot of the
time you are not present moment centered
you are focused on the next moment that
you need to get to so whatever you are
doing at this moment is
designed to get you to the next moment
and
internally you project yourself away
from what you're doing now because the
doing becomes a means to an
end this is very normal everybody lives
like that whatever they do is a means to
an end and meant in their mind the end
is more important than what they're
doing that is so habitual and
unconscious that most humans don't even
know that that is how they live that
they always live for the next moment but
they're never completely in this moment
they also don't know that by living in
that way they create frustration and
suffering and stress and
discontent basically they're condemning
themselves to continuous discontent and
to stress because if you ignore the
present
moment
continuously and ignore means you make
it into means to an end because the next
one is so important that you need to get
to then you miss life completely you
miss the depth
that potentially is there in life and
life becomes shallow because it's all
mental because the next moment is always
a mind formation the next moment is a
mental projection the next moment is
never a reality because it doesn't
exist when the next moment comes Okay
one minute from now I've got one minute
to finish
[Music]
this and then after 1 minute it's not
one minute it's oh it's now
again and then there's the next thing to
do of course immediately you look to the
next thing because you have
become used to be uncomfortable with the
present moment condition since childhood
to feel ill at ease in the present
moment oh I should be doing something
and doing
implies some future
projection you can never be you're
always doing as you get little tastes of
that State of Consciousness that we call
presence for example
now you feel yourself you feel your
presence right now Beyond
any
uh your Beyond any thought that's
connected with your life situation or
whatever it may be whether what age you
are becomes irrelevant what gender you
are becomes irrelevant and uh what you
have achieved or suffered in this world
it all it transcends all that it is more
powerful than any of
that it liberates you from all that it's
not that the person disappears
completely of course the person the
personal self is still there it
continues to operate in this world but
there's a continuous knowing that there
is more to you than that and that is
vital so you continue to operate as a
person in this world but no longer
deriving your identity from the personal
sense of self you can operate as a
person you need to In This World In This
World of time past and future you can
operate in this world without losing
yourself in this world and without
losing yourself in
identity that ultimately is a very
shallow and fleeting thing that you call
me the
person so that thing continues to
operate for a while
but your challenge
is while you operate in this world as a
person not to lose
connectedness with that deeper
Dimension and that is bringing presence
into every situation that you deal with
every
interaction in this world and that is a
skill that skill develops and isir
presence itself is
timeless but it is a skill for you
to it requires some practice at a high
degree of
alertness to bring presence into
everyday life whatever you do here
whatever function you have in this
world
function and for example not to confuse
your function with your
identity it's a
function I am a teacher of presence you
are a teacher of presence or you are
becoming a teacher of Presence by living
in that
way by
bringing that Consciousness into every
situation so that you
don't uh lose yourself in the doing of
whatever it is you're doing in the
situation and you don't lose yourself in
a sense of identity that's to do with
your function and to reduce you reduce
other people to their function in this
world I had a very extreme extremely
painful relationship with
myself I couldn't live with myself
anymore and so
I somehow said that's it I can't live
with it anymore that's it but that was
so
total that I no longer
sustained fueled the self through
thought I didn't know anything about it
it just
happened so the mindmade image dissolved
the self that I couldn't live with it
was
so heavy
dissolved and what was left was
simply
I so the eye shifted from where before
when I said I I was referring to myself
the unhappy dense eye the story based
eye that dissolved and then the
true
I emerged had always been
there
presence I
am nothing in particular anymore a
simple sense of presence of
beingness and for the first time I could
walk and be with without having a
relationship with
myself and that there is
something so precious in
that eye or
presence
[Music]
so it's beyond words you could say it's
like a diamond it's something extremely
very very precious that's why perhaps
Buddhism sometimes has the image of a
diamond but this is not
comparative it's not a sense
of that deepest self not the mindmade
self is so precious that it
has it knows itself to be that in a non
dualistic way without needing to compare
itself to other
it has nothing to do with a form or any
mind
form so as presence
arises you don't
need self-esteem anymore you don't
depend on that
anymore because what dissolves is the
mindmade entity with which you have a
relationship and it's so so self-esteem
is an intermediate thing that for a
little while makes your life more
pleasant it's
fine and
then after a while you see the
unsatisfactory nature even of that
because you cannot uphold
continuous self-esteem it's hard
work all these
affirmations and then things come into
your life that tell you the opp was
it inevitably sooner or
later so then suddenly you don't love
yourself anymore nor do you hate
yourself because there's no self to love
they're simply the state of this which
is love it emanates asking is the
ability to ask is
wonderful um please thank you the um
because if if you're truly asking there
is a you there's a space of
openness if you're truly asking you you
voluntarily enter the state of not
knowing so and this is a wonderful
ability to ask whatever it is so that
you be become a space you can ask a
person something
you can
ask the universe something and but there
needs to be the receptivity if you you
can ask any kinds of questions but the
question needs to
be the question needs to come out of the
spaciousness of which is there when you
truly ask there are many people who ask
questions and there's not the openness
to receive the answer and that is not
true
asking but to put yourself in this
basically it's connected with the state
of not
knowing so that you can and that's the
part of
the state of awareness is that you an
aspect of it is that you're in that
state of not knowing
conceptually so there's
a there's nothing more beautiful than
asking a question
and uh if it's directed to other human
beings
then people love to be asked true
questions and they can feel whether
there is an openness there or whether
you have certain
expectations as far as the answer is
concerned so that in itself is a
spiritual great spiritual practice to
ask how can we overcome or eliminate
stress and suffering and anxiety in our
lives when it seems to be crippling us
unhappiness is another word you could
use it's a generic term for any form of
negativity inside yourself unhappiness
suffering when so you begin to realize
that most of that arises from a mental
narrative about a situation or or about
your circumstances but not from the
circumstances themselves
and and then you can begin to
practice every time you feel upset is
arising some form of Nega anger is
arising some form of
negativity uh blaming people in
situations and saying this shouldn't be
happening or something is not happening
but it should be happening or they
should do this or they shouldn't do it
all kinds of narratives in your mind so
you spiritually Awakening is
you're beginning to be aware of what
your mind is
saying uh the the stor that you're
telling yourself about
situations but also the stories you're
telling yourself about what you call
your
life so because people there are
millions of people in this world who Liv
with a very painful sense of
identity they they perceive their life
as a bird so they live with this
heaviness and they don't
realize what they this heaviness that
they call my life is actually a
narrative that they tell themselves and
they say that's me all the things that
have happened to me the Dreadful things
in the past that people did to me or
circumstances did to me or maybe even
the bad things that I did so you get a
very heavy identity builds up and that
becomes your sense of self and people
don't reach realize it's a it's a story
you're continuously telling yourself in
your mind but you're are so identified
with a story that you don't exist you're
outside of the story when
you want
to strengthen the physical
body what do you
do you
exercise
but what what is that actually when you
exercise what do you do when you
exercise one way of putting it is to say
that you
create difficulty for the
body you create obstacles for the body
to
overcome whatever it is running on the
TR lifting weight
it's in you're creating a a difficulty
for the body any exercise is making life
difficult for the
body that's a way of looking at it
that's not a normal way of looking at
it you take the body out of its comfort
zone although there is a stage where the
body once it gets going the body may
enjoy the energy of it but until that
flows there's a
discomfort and that's the only
way the body can get
stronger
if the body stays in its comfort zone
then well you would be lying on a sofa
or in a deck
chair
it's very nice but the body doesn't
change
so that's an
interesting almost an analogy for
something that
happens to
humans because it seems that life for
everybody creates
difficulties so it's not one would have
thought if I were
God I would make life easy for
everybody
and you would then
see most likely if you did that most
likely there would
be no Evolution would ever have happened
or no further Evolution if you do it
right
now because it's only it seems both on
the physical level and
Beyond it's only through facing
difficulties which you could also call
challenges which you could also call
problems if you like which you could
also call one damn thing after
another the strange thing is only by
encountering these
challenges do we grow in Consciousness
and
generate energy it awakens us eventually
it is true that negative thinking can be
very
addictive I from my point of view it is
not caused by the chemical that's
generated in the brain although I do not
deny that
the chemicals in the body very often
reflect certain things that happen on
the mental emotional level but what
comes first the chicken or the egg so if
you if you become very angry of course
there are certain chemicals that are
released in the body and if you become
peaceful then they go the addiction is
not in the chemical other I don't deny
that there is a CH chemical component to
emotional states but it is the addiction
to negative
thinking and the addiction to negative
thinking is usually connected to the
pain body which is the emotional field
that Fields fed
fueled by the negative thinking so it
who addiction means it feels on some
level it feels good if you're addicted
to something on some level it feels good
if you're addicted to alcohol the
drinking feels good while you drink not
afterwards but while you drink so if
you're
addicted what who
feel to whom does it feel good not to
you not to the physical body because the
physical body suffers through it but to
the pain body this emotion loves to get
more of the same energy by generating
further negative thinking in your mind
and it feeds on it because it doesn't
get enough food through the drama in
your relationship so the awareness has
to come in so that you break the link
between your pain body and your thought
processes that is the key is to S the
link between your thought processes and
the pain body in order to sever the link
between those there needs to be enough
awareness presentence only the presence
can sever the link the presence comes in
and so you you no longer the emotion is
no longer controlling your thought
activity that's the
key and that's the beginning of the end
of that vicious circle that otherwise
will take over your life
so what is
needed is for you to be there
in the moments these thoughts occur or
immediately after and then immediately
look at the thought and say that again
and do not believe it and again it comes
back
to the state of
connectedness with being it's only from
that state of
connectedness with a deeper dimension of
who you are from
there it becomes easier to for give
because forgive means there was
something that was done on the level of
form by one life form to to you perhaps
another life form pain was
inflicted or whatever it may be treat uh
whatever the transgression
is
and it's only from there that you can
see
the relative nature of what was done
because you're in touch with a space
within you that was
never hurt by that that dimension in you
is beyond what can be
injured it's only the form can be
injured the psychological form somebody
might have insulted you deeply the
psychological form of who you are can be
can feel
pain or the physical form of who you are
pain and somebody inflicted
that out of
unconsciousness then recognizing the
first step in uh forgiving is to
recognize that this was an act of
unconsciousness on and you do not equate
what this person did with who that
person
is and it's only from the place of
connectedness with being that you can
say no longer hold a grievance about
that because you in touch with that
inside you that is beyond what can be
inured if you're not in touch with that
space then you're still it's hard to
forgive not to forgiving means not to
Harbor griev or resentment or any
negative feeling about
it and really that's only possible when
you are connected with the formless in
yourself instead of giving more
attention to your
thinking you just take your attention
into the inner energy field of the body
and suddenly you feel the aliveness that
pervades the entire
body and so you have taken Consciousness
away from the
mind and put it in here and you can't
think that much anymore you can't feel
the body and be engaged in a lot of
thinking and if you really fully
experience your liveness in the inner
body the Mind
stops and so that is a becomes an anchor
for awareness an anchor for
presence even if you just even if you
cannot feel the entire body it would be
enough to just go into your hands with
your
attention just take Consciousness into
your hands and feel the aliveness in
your hands that
alone can take attention away from
useless thinking and you continue to
feel because that is part of
experiencing the present moment which
actually feels quite good it feels good
to be alive
that's an amazing realization my North
Star is the monk the story you shared
about the monk who lived saying is that
so for everything that came I am
trying my best to get there in my
journey to accepting the isness of
things and accepting the moment what I'm
struggling with
is when am I being a doormat how do I
deter determine it's clear in the
example you just shared being homeless
in the gray areas of life how do I
determine when I need to take action the
important thing
is non-resistance is not so much to do
what externally what you do but it's an
it's an inner state of consciousness of
non-resistance acceptance of what is of
the present moment in this this moment
um it doesn't if it's misunderstood then
it could lead as you say it could lead
you to become a doormat because then you
would go along with with what everybody
say anybody says to you uh and you would
can you do this can you do this for me
yeah okay I can do it and then you you
could be used by
people
uh but a state of non of
nonresistance
sometimes
um may require you to say no to let say
somebody requests something but you feel
you don't want to do it or you cannot do
it uh for some
reason and you say
no I I don't I think I wrote about this
I I had this
expression a high quality no as oppos to
a low quality no a low quality no is you
make the other person
into a kind of
enemy why you always ask me this
like you argue and Sh you accuse the
other per you're just trying to use me I
can see it you've used me before and now
you're doing it again now you're asking
me for money again I've already lend you
five times have you given it back to me
no you haven't so no I'm not going to do
it just don't leave me alone that's one
no and then there's another no which is
nonreactive it's not AR does not arise
from reactivity but is a response to the
situation that says uh no I don't want
to let's say whatever the request is or
the
demand no I I can't do it anymore I
don't want to do it anymore no I'm not
going to give you money again because
I've already given you five times so
this I'm I won't give you again uh
that's just how it is I know I can't uh
no no I
[Music]
canot whatever it may be you're saying
no without creating an enemy without
treating or a situation without making a
situation into an
enemy so it's a conscious no and you're
still in an inner State of
non-resistance the State of resistance
strengthens the ego and this is a way of
not operating through not operating
through ego so I wonder could to connect
that to what I'm doing with this month
um I I suppose someone like you kind of
kind of digs something like this the
idea that someone could put down the
devices and I wonder what what do you
think just in general about a world that
is so obsess ly connected to other
people's thoughts all day long yes
that's good so um the over this um
excessive identification with thinking
and overthinking ex excessive thinking
have been the for a long time long
before we came up with these
devices but uh these devices uh amplify
the human tendency to to engage or
indulge in excessive thinking and
problem making thinking rather than
constructive thinking focused thinking
uh so the what you are doing uh is very
very helpful you are basically uh uh
having a period of what we could call it
decluttering your mind you declutter
your mind and this is necessary because
our mind most people's minds have never
been been as cluttered as they are
now uh clut means there's a continuous
input of stuff that comes in through the
devices uh the messages come in Facebook
posts uh tweets and continuously the
devices demand your attention and say
this is important and a lot of it is not
important but as we all
know there's an addictive quality to it
it draws your attention to it and then
every time it draws your attention you
add to the Clutter of your mind a lot of
that is not
constructive a lot of it is just random
people often see people they get out
their phones and they do this random
scrolling I can see it's random there's
nothing specific but they think they
have to do it because everybody else is
doing it around them wherever you are
these days people are engaging with this
and they're continuously taking in
thoughts from others and as we said
before some of these thoughts may be
toxic and they may easily become lodged
in your
mind uh so to declutter is extremely
important uh and you can see if you're
even just not using a device for a day
for many people is very very hard uh and
some think they can do it but they can't
so they are truly
addicted um now when you when you when
you declutter your mind first of all you
put down your phone you don't use it not
everybody can do it for whole months
like you of course of course but I
recommend to everybody to have certain
periods of time when they uh do not
engage so for example in your bedroom
might be a good place to T for not
engaging with any device uh certain
periods of time when you go out into
nature be there rather than carry that
thing and every time it makes a noise
you still look up and you're still even
while you're surrounded by Beauty and
aliveness you're still engaging with
this in
presence all this what I sometimes call
unnecessary
baggage that people
manufacture mentally and
emotionally all that unnecessary baggage
that really is a there a heaviness to it
that they carry
around doesn't arise anymore and this
the simple this is what is I can either
do this or I can do that I can deal with
it now I can put it aside this no story
but this is frustrating to the ego
because when there's no longer any story
where you oppose the
other where you make yourself feel
superior to the other then there's no
food for the ego
[Music]
anymore but there's an incredible
lightness and the lightness of being
comes and the heaviness goes out of
situations that really that's what the
ego is a heavy
me and even when
it attempts to make itself
Superior what it doesn't
recognize is that all these are really
forms of suffering the ego doesn't even
recognize suffering as suffering it
doesn't realize that when you get angry
or irritated about something somebody
else's behavior and bring up a big story
about it you are actually in a state of
suffering if you were able to have ATT
tension into in your body you would
notice that your body is suffering
because those things affect the smooth
harmonious working of the energy
field that goes through the body so an
an angry thought has an effect on the
body small irritation or has an effect
and the body doesn't really like
it but the ego the egoic self is not in
touch with the body so it and it
mistakes suffering for something
good anger can really get into
this
so you can look at your own life and see
where you are manufacturing unnecessary
stories both in small
situations and in bigger life
situations and in situations to do
with uh relatives family
members partners
ex Partners a wonderful source of egoic
stories and talk about your ex-husband
or wife for hours either to somebody
else if they're ready to
listen or in your own
mind or you had a confrontation or an
exchange with somebody yesterday and you
can go on continue that in your mind and
say so many hurtful things to the other
person that unfortunately you couldn't
think of in the
situation but you can relive it now and
it's almost as good as the real
[Laughter]
thing so in that fantasy world of the
mind you can be right again and again
and the other person can be wrong again
and again how
wonderful
[Laughter]
these things are not all this is what we
call unconscious so people don't
know what they are doing that's for them
that is their reality being is the one
thing of course it's not a thing we just
using
words is there one thing that you can be
absolutely sure about the only thing
that is beyond
doubt in your
life the only whose reality is beyond
doubt everything
else could be a dream or an
illusion whatever you
perceive could be a dream an
illusion you don't know that it's not a
dream Dre on
illusion because when this meditation
comes to an end then it evaporates into
the so-call
past and everything that happens
quickly dissolves dissolves
dissolves the same way the a dream comes
to an end when you wake
up except that this dream seems to go on
and on replaced by another and
another if it is a
dream but something what is it then that
cannot be
doubted that there
is a
Consciousness in which if it is a dream
whether it's a reality or dream just
matter in which it arises in which it is
known the light in which it
appears so your
presence cannot be doubted whatever
happens in that presence can be
doubted but for it to happen there must
be a presence and of course I said your
presence it's not your presence it's the
one universal
presence
Consciousness I particularly
welcome those of
[Music]
you who are getting tired of their
personality that cumber some that weight
you carry
around and creates the same old stuff
again and
[Music]
again it's a good point to
reach to become tired of
[Music]
yourself
that is sometimes
misperceived and then you think you're
tired of the world you're tired of
living you're tired of that's a
misperception what you're really tired
of is the
self and the world that it creates or
seems to create out
there
with the same old conflict the same old
problems or different problems but
basically the same if you deep
[Music]
down the same old thoughts in your head
again and again the same complaints oh
dear so the spiritual
path there are many practices you can
use in order
to access the dimension of presence
which is the spiritual
Dimension but the most
direct
practice
that
immediately accesses that
Dimension we could call
that
[Music]
surrender what is
that
it is to offer no resistance or
opposition to whatever arises in the
present moment whatever happens whatever
arises whatever people say or
do to become one
with the
isness of the present moment the present
moment always already is the way it
is there's no doubt about that whatever
Form This Moment takes it is as it
is and if internally then you give up
opposing which is the normal State
associated with dense
Personalities in instead of opposing
internally what
is getting upset getting angry arguing
with what is either just in your head or
out
aloud telling people what they should
have done or should be doing but I'm not
doing what it should be like but it
isn't like what I should be doing what
I'm not doing I should be whatever the
whatever form
the opposition
takes
and I
mentioned a few minutes
ago those of you who are getting tired
of the old personality and of course
this is part of the old personality the
way in which it interacts
with people and events and
places it's not usually
Pleasant there's always a some
resistance always something not good
enough always something missing Here and
Now wherever you go the structure stays
with you goes with
you so you recognize that that's an
important part
[Music]
of the false self that lives
through opposition to what is it
strengthens itself through that sense of
Separation separating itself from what's
going
on condemning it judging
it and
people and then you
realize what happens if I just accept
that whatever arises in the present
moment say oh that's what
is
you can still take action but Foundation
is acceptance
surrender and then immediately the false
self can't really operate
anymore and something else comes in
which is Essence which is awareness
which is consciousness itself
so the most fundamental spiritual
practice
is
surrender so that
internally you're one with what
is and immediately you are a spiritual
[Music]
master because that's all a master a
master does not necessarily have more
knowledge than you you may have much
more knowledge than spiritual
Master but the master lives in alignment
with the isness of the present moment
that's
all and that's where the power
arises because when you're aligned with
the
isness that inner spaciousness opens up
as Ence is
there and that is the power that then
moves through you and can become a
thought it can express itself in form
through a a thought an
action a
[Music]
movement some something you do or make
in many ways or just as an
emanation that is true full power when
you feel the need arise to be defensive
about
anything know that you have identified
yourself with an
illusion it is not danger that comes
when defenses are laid down it is safety
it is peace it is
joy and it is God
so when you feel the need arise to be
defensive about anything know that you
have identified yourself with an
illusion when you become defensive about
something
then it it will be something that is
conceptual you as a concept or some
concept you hold that you need to defend
because you have identified with it so
you are defending your sense of self
your fictitious sense of
self that means you're defending an
illusion when you don't defend because
the truth of who you are does not mean
to be
defended so to let go of
defenses can be a way
of
[Music]
practicing the deeper dimension of who
you
are and it course takes you beyond ego
because the defensiveness is ego ego is
conceptual identity in my
defenselessness my safety
lies you're safe
already so you don't need to defend
anything nothing real can be
threatened nothing unreal
exists herein lies the peace of
God here in meaning knowing
this lies the peace of
God I'll just let it be at that I not
going to interpret those lines I believe
it's a they're most powerful if you just
let them sink in whenever there is a
situation let's say at work or like an
emotional
relationship one of one side of my mind
is like this is not going to work out
blah blah and the other side is yes it's
going to work out no yes no and all day
long seriously I'm doing something and
in my mind they're going to lay you off
no they're not going to lay her off no
they're going to lay her off no
no it seriously comes to a point of
losing my mind
and sometimes but sometimes I know it so
strongly so I can calm myself down so I
just wanted to ask you how can I know
what's the right
answer I what's the voice of intuition
like how do I know the voice of
intuition instead of this
fighting okay okay well I believe uh
many people recognize your question
in it's a pattern in the human mind and
perhaps in you it's stronger than in
some who knows but it's in in many
people's
minds
uh so it's of course the the answer is
in and this is your
challenge is not trying to figure out
which of these voices is the right one
that's not
it it's to discover within
yourself that space that is not the
voice that space of
awareness so that can only you can only
practice that while it
happens there's that
voice and then there's the other voice
and who
is aware of these voices you don't need
to answer that question I'm just putting
it out don't answer it because there's
no answer there's only a direct
realization of it within yourself
there's no external answer because if
you give an answer that's another
voice so this is the question that you
should not answer in words so I'm asking
again who is it in you who or
what there's something in you that is
aware of these different conflicting
voices there is an awareness otherwise
you wouldn't know that there is a
voice now the voice is a these are
thought
formations these are energy every
thought is an energy field and each
thought formation wants
to draw your attention suck it up into
itself come here and the other one says
no come here these are like little this
may sound a little spooky but it's not
spooky uh what you can regard a
thought almost as an as an entity not
not a physical entity but as a as an
energetic entity and that lives there it
it has a it has a life span and some
thoughts uh persist for a long time and
certain thought patterns are also
entities that can shift take on one form
and then another form and another form
so you have every thought is a little
entity or energy
field it wants to it wants
your identification with it it wants to
draw your all your attention in because
the more tension get it get drawn in the
more it grows it wants to grow it wants
to like everything wants to it wants
doesn't want to disappear so it's for
you to know when this
happens who am I you
are are you this voice or that voice no
you are aware of the voice all these
voices and that is the place where you
you go so that from that place of aware
presence the voices are no longer
disturbing you you recognize them as
only a voice this is not important
whether you go this way or that way or
whether something is going to work out
or something is not going to work out
you don't know that your responsibility
is to be present which means to
disidentify from the voices adversity
can I either it can strengthen the
ego or it can gradually or in some cases
suddenly dissolve the ego or at least
diminish it it can go either way and I
must agree with you I don't know whether
you literally said it in perhaps still
in the majority of cases it strengthens
the ego because nobody know people don't
know the opportunity that adversity
represents so why does it happen how
does it strengthen the ego you can see
it sometimes with people who are sick or
people who are disabled who let's say
I've met disabled people people with
physical disabilities for example and in
some cases they are
very really angry with the world and
bitter because look at what happened to
me they say why do I can't move anymore
I've been Afflicted with this what have
I done to deserve this and these are all
questions that are still the justifiable
questions the the question what what
have I done to deserve why has the world
or whatever they say God the world the
universe or whoever they've done this to
me why and then they become bitter and
angry and the E ego becomes more and
more rigid and hardened and
[Music]
and and that is one way it could go and
then I have met people with
disabilities who through their
disability at some point whether through
a spiritual teaching and in some cases
never come into contact with any
spiritual teaching it just happened that
at some moment
they realized
intuitively that all the
suffering was
generated through
resistance and then the resistance to
the isness of their life this
moment they were able to let go because
perhaps the suffering was getting too
much something happened something
clicked
inside or even if didn't happen
completely uh they were able to have
moments of uh inner peace an inner peace
that is not caused by an external
condition an inner peace that seems to
be in cont contradiction to an external
condition so that they would How could a
person who is suffering this feel so
peaceful and so
um also that applies to people who are
um approaching the end of their lifespan
because they have some illness and they
have been to the doctor and the doctor
says you have six months or one year and
and
suddenly something Inland opens up and
all that remains
is the the person already dies there's
no more future
and All That Remains is the present
moment and the the aware space so I've
had the privilege of working with when I
was still seeing
individuals with two or three people to
whom that
happened and they became luminous beings
in the last few weeks or months of their
lives and became
just there was no wasn't I couldn't see
that there was any person left there was
only a space of conscious presence left
just wonderful as as if they had just
come into this world so they came and
then they came to me and then still
asking questions very profound questions
wanting to understand what happened and
it's
beautiful so this can happen it can
happen collectively to people who
have who go through Warfare and in
countries or become refugees they lose
everything and again it can go either
way uh whenever there's any great loss
in your life that again an opportunity
opens up if if you resist and you you
resist uh the resistance origin the
origin of the resistance is a narrative
that forms in your
mind uh that says something about the
situation and about your life and about
other people uh so the narrative forms
in your mind and the narrative is an
unhappy one and then there's
continuous resistance and nonalignment
with the isness of the present moment
now one could ask well how could
somebody who has lost who's lost their
home perhaps even lost love loved
ones and then they don't know where to
go how could this person be in a state
of alignment with the pro present moment
isn't that how can how can somebody
accept the
unacceptable accept that which in
conventional terms would be regarded as
unacceptable how is that how is that
possible but that's precisely it if you
can accept the unacceptable that is the
sudden the opening and then you realize
the unacceptable is actually not
unacceptable it is
acceptable and the I was homeless for a
certain period in my life with not
knowing what what to live on
the next day or the next week and uh uh
I had already gone into the state of
acceptance so it was a very pleasant
experience but potentially would have
been extremely unpleasant so not having
a home was for me already something that
was not experienced as something bad but
I knew I had to take some action
eventually to to get a home and so
gradually something happened I don't
want to talk too much about that I also
mentioned in
the new us I believe um there when I was
at University there was
the Steven Hawkins the physicist who was
confined to a wheelchair passed away
couple of years ago it was um he would
always he wasn't famous at that time
only famous locally in the University we
would always be in the same dining room
having lunch but not the same table I
never met him wasn't introduced observed
him many times C he at a neighboring
table and I then I the one moment when I
hold held open the door for him he was
coming through on his
wheelchair and I looked into his eyes
and I could see there was no unhappiness
if you find the strange phenomenon that
you are always right and others are
always wrong that's an important
realization how is that possible I must
be
superhuman and in the eyes of the ego of
course that's kind of the
case because the
ego which is that which is perhaps the
major
obstacle towards the
realization of that deeper
dimension in the the
ego
strives
incessantly
for some kind of
superiority and so this is what your
condemned
to when you have not
yet awakened
even to at least to some
extent to the deeper essence of who you
are the
awareness the
presence the
Stillness then you are in the
prison of your own
personality and it's not a pleasant
place to
be I sometimes watch
people and they are
so burdened with their personality so in
the
grip of that thing what is
personality it's the S to
of their mental emotional
conditioning from the
past mental emotional conditioning
mental conditioning means certain
thought forms mind structures that
become
repetitive certain
narratives
concerning your life my life says the
ego narrative
concerning my other people in my life
what I did what they did to me my
victories my defeats many things form
the the egoic condition self and one
important aspect of the egoic condition
self is it it talks
about my life all the the time in the
head and out
aloud and my
life is what concerns me obviously it's
my life and what is my life it's a story
in my head but they don't know
that they think it's the reality but
it's a story in my head it's a narrative
it's a predominant
narrative in my
mind and it's the narrative through
which I
interpret everything that come that that
come into contact with it becomes a
screen through which I interpret other
people
situations places
events I don't know that because I am so
identified with that mental emotional
condition conditioning that it has
become me it has become me and my life
it's I don't know anything
else that's the Fate
still of
the
majority of humans on the
planet although the the minority that is
Awakening is
growing it is still
a
minority most humans are still
totally in the
grip of their egoic self and
probably most of
you are moving still in and out of your
egoic self take your attention more
deeply into being or into attention
itself purely practical don't turn on
the TV in your
room
please I have not installed hidden
cameras to check on
you second limit your interaction the
interaction with your devices
if you cannot eliminate interaction with
your devices completely and I understand
that you may not survive if you
do at least put aside just maybe once a
day 15 minutes when you check your
whatever it is that comes
through
whatever
text email
um
Facebook um Snap
Chat
uh
Tinder it's all very important
but there's something more important and
that's why you're
here if
you so now let's see I suggest to you
that
you make an agreement with
yourself that not to uh go
there
unless any more than is absolutely
necessary let's just uh take a
moment become
aware of the present
moment vitally important
important in any
Endeavor that you
undertake no matter what it
is is not to
lose your
connectedness with the present
[Music]
moment so before you start a new
Enterprise and new
activity always go to take a moment
for awareness basically that's what it
is uh sometimes people ask well what is
the present moment how how do you
be where is it what does it even mean to
become aware of the present
moment and uh the first thing of course
is that you become aware of whatever
surrounds you that's the entry point
into the present moment a very easy
entry point into present moment
awareness some people may call it
mindfulness is to become more aware of
whatever surrounds you here and
now sense perceptions just be with what
is give it attention some attention
the room you're sitting
in maybe there's a window you can look
out of the
window you can see trees behind me I
can't see them I know they're
there this is you enter the Present
Moment
by becoming more aware of sense
perceptions auditory Visual and perhaps
other
this and of course what that does you
might
notice is there's
less mental
noise the voice in the head that speaks
and
speaks that talks to you that you have a
dialogue with a monologue that comments
and interprets
and
takes positions mental positions
identifies with likes dislikes yes
no never stops
talking that's the mind the the voice in
the head that most people are completely
identified with and that means they're
not present so the first step is take
some attention away from that by simply
becoming aware of sense
perceptions
and if you can look at something
natural that's even better because a
natural thing a tree a flower a plant
the
sky uh a natural thing uh lends
itself
to present moment awareness more than a
man-made human made thing so anything
natural that you can look at for a
moment focus on
and give it attention acknowledge it you
don't need to think about it so it's
just come aware of the present moment
through sensory perception and already
um if you can do that if perhaps a few
minutes before you were very much
immersed in
the problem making mind it wasn't
actually solving any problem
because this continuous mind
activity actually creates more problem
than it
solves if it's not focused it's
unconscious so already suddenly there's
a certain amount of peace that descends
upon this the world your
world it becomes a bit more peaceful you
become aware of the aliveness of things
be aligned with the present moment
rather than carry in your
head this huge amount of mental
content about your past and your
future because the mind is primarily
concerned with past and future so while
you're walking here you're already
thinking about in a week's time I'll be
home again and then what then I'll have
to do that and I have those phone calls
to make and then I'll have to do that
and those problems will be I I shouldn't
have come here because I've got Ser so
much on my plate at home why did I come
here I should have dealt with my things
there I I should have waited gone to
next year's
Retreat I said that's the selft talk in
the head you will May encounter it here
too as you walk from here to there you
will encounter the selft talk in the
head
so how do you get out of the selft talk
in the
head
one you need to know that that selft
talk in the head if you don't know it
selft talk in the head you become the
selft talk in your head you become the
voice in your head you don't know it you
are
it so you have
to the the vital step and I cannot tell
you how to do
that that minimum of awareness needs to
be there where you know that there's
selft talk happening in my head and it's
telling you some kind of story it could
be the briefest of stories like I
shouldn't have come here
or I don't fit in here all these people
are too spiritual for
me
[Music]
or I'm so spiritual these people are not
spiritual at all
oh it's all little stories in the head
every every even every fragment of selft
talk is a little story in the head that
goes
around and then you look at reality
through the length of the little story
it's not just one story of course it
comes another one it's another and and
some little some stories are not little
they may be big
stories about yourself
and your life and what's gone wrong with
it or what's gone right with it even
that's a
story more pleasant than if it's gone
wrong so you you need to know when the
self selft talk happens in the
head The Knowing is not part of The
selft Talk The Knowing is just an
awareness that there is selft talk the
moment there is an awareness that there
is selft talk the possibility of Freedom
From The selft Talk opens up I will
probably be
talking for most of the
time but there may
be quite a few gaps of Stillness in
between the
words as they are now
and these gaps are very
important I would even say more
important than the words if you become
conscious of these gaps of
Stillness in between
[Music]
words you notice the
gaps instead of just
impatiently being in your conceptual
mind and saying why is he talking so
slowly why hasn't he said anything if
significant
yet if you are able to notice the gaps
give them
attention that is the arising of that
State of Consciousness that we call
presence
it is a state
of
alertness Relaxed
alertness
Clarity
a state in which the conceptual
mind has come to
rest and something else
arises thinking is most people's normal
state of when they are awake in
conventional
terms and when you become aware of these
gaps thinking
subsides and presence or we call it
awareness
arises thinking
subsides presence arises of course
thinking will come back but it has
briefly momentarily subsided something
else has
emerged and
that is what we call
presence it is a state
of one could say pure awareness or pure
Consciousness
so that is what sometimes
people hope to achieve in medit when
they actually do formal
meditations um meditation is a good
tool but it's not
enough it's not even for
everybody the most important thing is to
bring that state of clear alert
presence in into everyday life there was
a long time when I had resentment
towards my father because my father was
pretty unconscious except for very late
in life had a very strong ego and living
with him as a child uh was living with
an unexploded bomb that could go off at
any moment got these intense rages would
suddenly several times a week so I lived
in a constant state of kind of uh uh
background anxiety but is when is this
bomb going to explode again next and
then for a long time in my 20s I had a
resentment towards him until I went to
this shift in Consciousness and I
suddenly
realized he he did what he had to do
there wasn't enough awareness in him to
act any different so he was at the mercy
of his own
conditioning um and once you see that
you no longer make it into an identity
for him uh and so you free him and
really perhaps this is the meaning of
forgiveness you can forgive yourself by
not making unconscious behavior in your
past into an identity for yourself or
for somebody else you may be surprised
to know that there are millions billions
of people on the planet who have that
same thought pattern there's something
wrong with me it's part of the human
ego but so you bring in the
awareness and that will change
everything that's the only true
key if you fail next time you the anger
arises what happens you will become
aware immediately after the anger has
subside it and then oh there it was and
I wasn't
present and then the that the moment
will come when you are there in the
first if you can catch the anger the
first moment it
comes or if you might even see that it's
could be the result of a thought that
creates the anger and if you can be
there in the first moment before it
becomes to fully blown anger then you
can stay there and it might not even
become fully blown anger if you catch it
the first moment you can feel the first
stirrings of anger you may only have 3
seconds you may come very quickly anger
is like an explosive energy you may only
have two three four 5 Seconds to to to
bring the stay there with your awareness
and feel it oh it's coming there it is
that's the pain body the angry pain body
coming and if you catch it in the early
stage don't suppress it by catch it I
mean feel it be there as a WI
then you can stay even as it grows the
witness grows with it it may not even
grow we'll have to see whether it still
grows into full-blown anger or not that
doesn't
matter and so you be thankful for your
anger
because the anger can be become a very
important spiritual practice for you
because through it awareness can grow
so it's it's a sometimes strange for
people to see you can be thankful for
things that you think are the most
difficult obstacles in your life but
they
become they can become the greatest
opportunity for for Spiritual Awakening
use it as part of your practice life
without love is no life at
all now what does that mean life life
without
love love can only be there when you're
connected to the source of
Life who you are Beyond
form Stillness spaciousness and then
from
there you
perceive you
relate you operate you do what you
do and
there's a sense of Oneness no longer a
sense of Separation you're one with the
present
moment you're one with whoever you meet
because the separation comes through con
mental
Concepts and that sense of Oneness is
love it's a recognition
that you
share with every life form you
share the same
Consciousness so it's always a self
recognition you see you sense rather
than see yourself in the other that is
love there's an innate human feeling you
see something and it has a lot of
attention and it's shiny and it's
whatever and that everyone wants to get
in but basically you're saying if you
would take that breath if you would just
say I don't want in on this that
eventually you can actually you can
almost pull other people out of it too
by your own behavior yes because this
isn't just about you yes also not to
feed uh other if other people post
negative things about you in many many
cases non-reaction is the best thing
instead of feeding it that's a lesson I
need to learn I will try to take that
one with me that applies both offline
and online in your personal life too
often it's just well I believe Jesus was
talking about non-reaction when he
talked about turning the other cheek I
don't think it's to be taken
literally but it means when somebody
somebody attacks you not not physically
it's an analogy he uses it's a parable
uh turn on the other cheek is means to
just be free of
reaction and that uh that uh very
quickly deflates even the the other
person's ego it doesn't the ego needs
the reaction it needs the
reactivity so that's a powerful thing
but how do you avoid then just becoming
a pushover within that well in some
situations something needs to be said
but even then that can come from you
could
say let's especially if you're with
somebody that kind of behavior is
unacceptable you can say that um in a
conscious way rather than then in a
destructive and aggressive way you can
one can actually be very firm and
conscious uh or when you say no to
somebody uh it doesn't have to be
aggressive uh it's just a a clear is I
call it a high quality
no uh somebody says can you lend me
again I've uh uh $2,000 I need I know I
still owe you 20,000 but I need some
more and then and then not to make the
other into an enemy just no I'm sorry
can't do it anymore it's a high quality
no that's a you're present while you say
it and then you can set boundaries if
necessary so in some cases uh something
needs to be said we need to do something
but in many other cases complete
non-reactivity can be very very powerful
can we trust our
feelings now often you hear people say
trust your
feelings I would suggest
however that that's not necessarily
true acknowledge your
feelings yes be there as the observing
presence for your feelings
yes be aware of your feelings accept
that they are
there trust which
means to take them to be the truth or
the truth for
you or using them as a guide to correct
or
skillful action that may be doubtful
because it depends where these feelings
arise in
you
a little anecdote from my life to
illustrate
that when I lived in England in the
country in that alternative town
glastenbury for 3
years I lived in a
cottage
and once a months I would travel to
London or other cities in my
beloved Russian made L
car and to do a
workshop and usually a weekend
Workshop uh
called things
like transcending
time or be here
now nothing much has
changed except that my the average
number of people I had was about
10 and since my income was not enough I
had to rent out a room upstairs in my
Cottage so I had
to over these three year three years a
few
people even was a second
room AAS
anyway the room became vacant I
advertised in the local local paper
several people came to apply and and
finally chose a young uh woman who had
just been offered a job in that town she
came she moved
in and after the first night in her room
she came down for breakfast into the
kitchen which was a sad kitchen and she
said I can't stay
here what's wrong I just I just it's
just a feeling and I always listen to my
feelings I just I just can't stay
there's something not
right he was very
nervous and uh I said okay that's
fine and that she found that very
disconcerting because she had expected a
more conventional
response which would have been what I've
interviewed all these people I've chosen
you and now what you doing this to me
I'm you're you're not getting your rent
money back that you pay in advance but I
said okay I'll give you your money back
it's fine so she was even more confused
after
that and I said he said I'll spend one
more night or two more nights she spent
the second night and then in the morning
she
said uh no I think I'll
stay I have a different feeling
now and
I said oh that's fine that's
good and again she was a little
disconcerted because the conventional
response would have
been which I did do I just put another
ad in the
paper and now you're telling me
this this this is how to make the
conventional responses are how to make
life complicated for yourself and others
but it's not noral it's how the ego
responds and so whenever somebody does
not respond in that way life becomes
simple but when life becomes simple
people who expect the conventional
responses become confused what this is a
weird
person and so she decided to stay and a
few weeks later when I got to know how
better
she explained to me that that first
night she was in her
bedroom and she
said I found you so weird that I I
thought you might creep in in the middle
of the night and murder
me
and later she said living in the same
house with you is like living in a float
tank I think she learned a lot not so
much through me explaining things to her
just by being there there
uh not that she didn't go through her
episodes
of neurotic reactivity which is quite
normal for most people but that's
fine uh so feelings now where did her
the initial feelings that she
experienced that she that she
then
uh believed that they were
correct guide for action of course they
were not because they originated in
fear and they also originated in a
misinterpretation of
reality which is so easy to do for the
mind to misinterpret another person to
misinterpret a situation you
misinterpret because you see it through
the conditioning of your
mind you see it through your
beliefs your prior experiences in
childhood you see it through even other
things that have conditioned your mind
maybe even scary movies about weird
people who don't say
much and then just when you're having a
shower they creep
in
so the it is not therefore it's not that
easy often to to say where does this
feeling that I have
arise where does this feeling originate
how do we deal with a collective problem
with through presence or through
reactivity and if if we deal through by
the
way when you deal with something through
presence it means there's wisdom this is
another important
word
wisdom arises out of
presence wisdom is different from
intelligence intelligence is the ability
to use the conceptual
mind that has its purpose it's fine but
there is something deeper and more
important in every potentially in every
human being and that's not intelligence
it's wisdom wisdom is the this faculty
that arises out of presence and then you
can deal with situations truly
intelligently rather than reactively and
you do not make the situation worse by
your reaction to the
situation um so you need wisdom what the
world needs is not more intelligence
very soon AI is become probably becoming
more intelligent than
humans and and the human challenge is to
access the dimension where wisdom
arises that's
com computers don't have that they can't
be very good at thinking
probably they're making incred rible
advances but not wisdom wisdom so we
need to as as we are being almost
replaced
by artificial
thinkers uh this
coincides with the transition of human
beings to a higher state of
consciousness than thinking where of
course they can still think but they are
not trapped in
thinking and so it's terribly
important and again coming back for a
moment to that situation um Collective
situation there's a collective
challenge we had the
uh um pandemic situation as a huge
Collective
challenge was there wisdom in the way in
which we
reacted to their
challenge not very
much there was a lot of fear there was a
lot of panic there lot of
anger uh
and many measures were
taken not necessarily seeing all the
possible repercussions of measures that
were taken that would still play
themselves out in the next few years we
don't need to go into uh details but the
question is always do you create more
suffering by your reaction to a
situation than is contained in the
situation itself that's lack of wisdom
does
that and lack of wisdom means lack of
presence or awareness whatever word you
want to use the normal thing to happen
is that this the connectedness with your
essence identity is lost very easily in
human
relationships because the mind is so
active and we live in a civilization
that provides continuously continuous
and
incessant stimulus stimuli is the plural
continuous incessant stimuli for the
mind even more than even 30 years
ago 30 years ago it was just radio and
television and you would people would
sit there for
hours but nowadays you have countless
sources of stimulus for the for the mind
that draws you into
continuously thinking
about what's your next Facebook post
what's it going to be and you look at
the ones that are coming in all these
people are doing these fantastic things
and me I'm just sitting here and then
you have to pretend that you're also
doing fantastic
things and usually it involves taking a
nice
selfie and then you project yourself
image which has existed for a long long
time before in humans they have a they
have part of ego is to have this image
of who I
am and but in in these Divi Facebook now
you have the opportunity to project that
image into the world and it'll reach
hundreds or thousands of
people all at
once and then you you construct your
life you there are many people alive
these days who without knowing it they
partly live for their Facebook image and
they're just looking for the next thing
that they can project out into the world
it's
narcissus you might remember the my of
Narcissus the Greek ancient Greek myth
there was this young man who had never
seen himself before because they didn't
have mirrors at the time but one day he
happened to look into a little pool of
water and he saw himself and he realized
that he was extremely beautiful he said
oh that's
me and The Story Goes he fell in love
with himself not in a good
[Music]
way not by becoming one with who he is
but but the separation happened this mis
chose the the beginning stage of the
egoic sense of self expressed as a story
the image that he of himself in a pool
is the mental image of the EG that and
stories are part of that image that's me
I'm me in my story so you have the image
of me and then oh so this guy
nissus he experienced that
separation
uh and then I think something bad
happened to him but I don't remember
what so and then you have other divine
things that continuously stimulate the
mind that almost designed for you not to
not to to to become still it's like the
civilization has made a great effort to
come up with as many things as possible
to prevent people from becoming still
and spacious and had taking a moment
of looking at the sky and feeling the
spaciousness arise and becoming aware of
the the leaves of the tree or the
branches and the wind blowing
and the noise of
water the simple thing becoming still
alert
sensing that Stillness within almost
everybody uh has in one way or
another being a victim of other people
but in some cases much much more so than
in
others some element of having been
victim is probably present in
everybody's life uh in other words you
are surrounded by unconscious humans and
then unconscious humans will inflict
suffering on themselves and others
that's just how it is when you alive in
this on this
planet uh childhood particularly is a
place where many many children
experience um
abuse either minor forms of abuse
emotional abuse or they live in a very
toxic family environment and then of
course there are other children who
experience much more serious forms of
abuse and really
uh suffer and have these
carry carry with
them the the memory both mental and
emotional memory of uh what happened to
them in some cases the memory is
repressed because the child uh the
emotions may be repressed the child
could not deal with them and they had to
repress them and then later the
possibility of remembering arises and
then you remember what happened to you
and how do you do it's the question what
do you do with what happened to you what
was done to you how do you deal with
what was done to you by other humans
whether it happened in
childhood or whether it happened later
in
life whether it was a relatively minor
thing or whether it was a very serious
form of
abuse how do you how do you deal with
that h
now the the ego the human
ego is always looking for something to
add to its sense of identity it's
looking for a stronger sense of identity
because it always feels I'm not enough
so it's it's going it's trying to add
something that it can identify with so
add to its sense of self
and it very often happens that uh the
memory of of having been
abused is used by the
ego and is added to the ego's sense of
self so that means you not only remember
what happened to you the memory of what
happened to you which
is a bundle of thoughts and emot tion
that go with it the memory of what
happened to you is more than just a
memory there is
self-identification with the memory in
other words it's not not perceived as
just something that happened to you but
it becomes part of who you perceive to
be so I am a victim of that it's not
that this was done to me but I am a
victim of is the transition from memory
to
self that is the victim identity the ego
does that uh
because victim identity is a very
powerful form of identity a very
powerful form of
ego and particularly in cases
where the the ego is always
is does not find
sufficient things that it can identify
with in this world because the the most
common form of identification for
example is with the way you
look uh you look better than others so
you can identify with that if you look
worse than others of course that we
could become part of your victim
identity because you've been treated
unfairly by life and and life has made
you look worse than others that could
become part of victim identity Al that's
not actually abuse but it could all also
be incorporated into victim identity
there are millions of people in this
world who believe in
God and have no access have not found
within themselves access to the
spiritual
dimension
so we are
here in the case of some of you who are
perhaps new to this so to speak we are
here for some of you to get perhaps a
glimpse of it as you sit here and watch
and
listen and I will endeavor to put you in
touch with that
depths Within You Without which your
life is
frustrating and without which everything
you undertake every Endeavor and
every
activity ultimately becomes
frustrating and for
others we're here just to to deepen it
to provide a reminder on a conceptual
level but to deepen the dimension that
they already have access to
within so that it can be sustained in
everyday
life one thing
is accessing the spiritual dimension in
a meditation setting like here and now
that's already a good thing if you are
able to do that when you sit
still become still
inside another thing is
to carry that with you so to speak so
that it is there when you lead your
life when you do
things talk to people
interact even when you think
to have that in the
background so we have the two steps one
could almost say first is you you
realize that within when you're not
being disturbed like now hopefully
you're not being disturbed externally
although you may be disturbed as you sit
here by your mind that's quite possible
who says what is he talking
about because the mind doesn't
understand it the conceptual mind alone
is not sufficient to make this a
satisfying experience for you so for
this to be a
satisfying experience you need
to have at least a glimpse of what it is
that I am pointing to and a glimpse also
of that which underlies the
words
and that's ultimately not in me but
ultimately you can only Glimpse that in
you there's a Stillness behind the
words as I speak Within
Myself And there can be a Stillness in
you as you listen to the
words and that would already be a
glimpse of the spiritual Dimension so
part of this is of course to be give
more attention to the present
moment because the more you think the
more future you
[Music]
generate and the more attention you give
to the present
moment the less thinking because to be
really present you don't think about it
you just are with it give it attention
I recommend the little things of life to
be more
attentive to all the little things that
make up every hour of every
day every minute every
hour and give them more
[Music]
attention walking steps while one step
at a
time objects that you're handling you're
all the time you're handling objects in
your life they
always touching something putting
something here
there is everything that you handle just
a means to an end or are you able to
just appreciate the simple presence even
of a so-called inanimate
object
contemplation also of all the lovely
things that make up your
environment part of your
environment for example if I were
sitting here
alone let's say I'm waiting for
everybody to
arrive I might be sitting here looking
of course at the
flower sense the Stillness and then
there's a glass table
here and then there's a glass of water
here and there's a clock and a bell and
tissues and they all reflect the light
in different
ways there's a little bit of a rainbow
effect in the glass of water
here and then the the lights are
reflected on the the belts almost like a
mirror
and there's the clock ticking
away it's a beautiful scene sometimes
you go to an art gallery well not so
much with modern art but a very favor
favorite thing would be still Al artist
and it took a while in art before they
discovered the the artists in the
history of art before they discovered
the seemingly insignificant things and
started to give attention to those
before that happened they were very much
interested in the huge things the Saints
or the Kings or the huge battle scenes
or the the big they had to they painted
those things or the important
people or some dramatic thing volcanic
eruption or whatever fire uh
and then at some point they started to
discover the Beauty and the
[Music]
incredible sense of the quality that is
in the little things perhaps after these
more of these artists depicted
relatively in seemingly insignificant
things perhaps it motivated some people
to give more attention to that
but even now it's still people very much
Overlook that and you you overlook then
a large part of your life you don't give
it
attention when I say give attention
there's an element ofec appreciation of
everything of the little things and you
begin to realize that your entire life
consists mainly of little things
nonattachment to things does not mean
not
appreciating
things but it means
not seeking
yourself or to regard thing things as an
extension of
yourself or think of things as needing
them to add to
yourself in order to be yourself more
fully
that's attachment to
things it's an an
ego dysfunction but in in way in which
the ego
survives and it's it's not pleasant
because you always need more and nothing
really satisfies you when if ever
you buy something and seek some kind of
self saatis isfaction through it very
quickly you realize it doesn't work and
then you look for something
else however there is a way of
appreciating things beautiful things or
simple
things appreciate is not being attached
you can love even
love a piece of furniture or whatever it
is a little object or a piece of
something you wear too not saying all
this needs to disappear you can you can
like things and appreciate them love
them in a sense of having
appreciate without the without
the self-seeking in
it and when it the thing leaves
you it you you lose it or it breaks or
or it gets stolen or
whatever without the attachment you'll
say oh it's a Pity but you don't there's
no reaction and no pain you're able to
let go and that's a sign that something
you appreciate it and yet when it's not
there anymore well that's all right
too I always appreciate it
since I
I started in my between the age of 30
and well up to the age of 30 I don't
know
my my main transportation was
bicycle and I always had a I always
appreciated my
bicycle uh and I developed the strange
habit when I parked my bicycle and
changed it to something a railing
outside
whatever I would take a few steps and
look back on it and just appreciate it's
its being it's a very strange habit you
look back at it and look back one more
time there it
is and sometimes people ask why are you
looking back at your bicycle are you
proud of it it well it wasn't a
particularly special bicycle just a
normal no it just I I appreciate it it
being
there and
uh one day when then I got in I Got a
Car somebody gave me an old car and then
I lend my bicycle to somebody and one
and suddenly that person came and said
I'm so sorry I lost your
bike I didn't lock it for a few minutes
and not it's
gone and it I had already gone through a
shift in Consciousness so I it's okay
it's gone nothing we can do about it
hopefully somebody else appreciates it
now then I developed the same habit with
my old car I would look back when it I
parked it I'd look back and just
appreciate it being there and I do the
same now that I have a much better car
and now with my good car people think I
must be proud of this car or something
but it's not that I did the same with
the
bicycle it's a strange habit I'm not
recommending anybody that he should do
that but it's just it's a one a way in
which I appreciate it it it's being in
this world dealing with
things creating things achieving
things and being is
about being aware
of the present
moment which after all is all you ever
have whatever you achieve through
becoming in the future
eventually turns into the present moment
so as I speak to
you the meditation if we even want to
call it
that it's perhaps best to forget about
the
word as I
speak
be aware of
the St the silence or the
Stillness between the
words being aware means just notice that
it's there it's very
simple so you notice
that in addition to the
words there's another
dimension that is easily
overlooked and that's the dimension
of
Stillness which we could also
call
space
or
spaciousness so when you
notice that there are
two so to
speak two
Dimensions here
the dimension
of
Words which
you
hear and which then
become
thoughts in your
head
and the dimension
of
no
thing
spaciousness you just so you just notice
that's all that's
required that there is that Dimension
also present so you notice
it in between
words and
even behind the
words so to
speak now when you notice
it what
happens inside you what does it mean to
notice the
Stillness
be aware of the
Stillness it
means you have become
still
inside it
means you're
conscious but at that moment at this
moment moment you're not
thinking but you're
alert
present completely
here but not
thinking
so that's the
realization of the dimension of
depth within you when the Buddha was
teaching 2,500 years ago he told people
to seek out a a quiet place in the
forest and meditate there
that was an essential part of his
teaching so nature was an essential part
of his
[Music]
teaching and of course as you know
probably The Story Goes that the Buddha
sat under a
tree when as The Story Goes he awakened
spiritually or became enlightened so his
Enlightenment is
associated with the
tree a
tree don't believe what science tells
you there's more to the tree than
that and you can know and sense
that if you become still enough and give
it your
attention
looking almost sensing its
Stillness so but it is a reciprocal
movement it goes both ways
yes nature becomes conscious of itself
through
you but nature
also helps
[Music]
you to realign
yourself with Stillness how do I strike
a healthy balance between simply
accepting life as it
unfolds and actively working towards and
striving toward goals destinations
aspirations well accepting life as it
unfolds of course is the foundation for
conscious and sane living accepting
whatever unfolds in the present moment
there is nothing
else that's the foundation does that
mean you
cannot have
goals you cannot have aspirations
wanting to achieve this do this do that
it's perfectly compatible with accepting
what is arriving in this moment one
difference between the unconscious state
which denies this moment and wants to
make it into a means to an end all the
time the difference then
is what is the motivation for your
doing If you deny this moment
can never embrace it honor it appreciate
it then the motivation for your action
is basically
dissatisfaction with what is and the
action is looked towards as a possible
way of
overcoming the discontent and the
disatisfaction that you feel with the
present
moment and that's a very normal pattern
and that's in for many many people that
what is what motivates them they don't
feel good enough they don't
feel there some they feel there's
something fundamental missing in their
lives they don't feel recognized they
don't feel loved whatever and so they
try to find something achieve something
that will bring them that which they
feel is
missing they don't realize that
it's that is not going to work you need
to start
with the foundation for your life which
is this moment and go deeply into that
and
become okay with it friendly with it
realize it's the only thing that ever is
just this moment nothing ever exists
that's not this moment so you might as
well become friendly with it and
appreciate it it and look around and see
how actually it's okay this moment is
actually
okay and if it's not okay you can still
say well that's what is right now if
something goes wrong that's what
is and then things will come in that you
want to do you suddenly an idea comes or
you need to do something to make a
living and then out of that state of
becoming one with the isness of the
present moment something arises and
wants that wants to take form in the
world that perhaps you want to create
and then you create it out of the joy of
doing instead of out of a feeling of
lack that you need something to make you
complete or
happy so the motivation changes from
neediness and discontent
too joyful
doing it's not stressed anymore when
stress is a sign that you've lost the
present moment the next moment has
become more important than life itself
the greatest obstacle is
probably uh when meditation comes out of
a sense of a lack or
neediness so you feel you you are
deprived of something be it money
or uh a relationship or a living
situation and you feel there's a great
lack in your life and you desperately
want this to
change and so you
perhaps uh use manifestation in a way
that is not likely to work when for
example you use affirmations such as
uh I want a better job I want a job with
an a good income and a life situation in
a nice place and I want this and I want
that um by making these
statements uh you're actually by
implication saying that you don't have
it so you're also by saying that
you're uh uh there's a reverse side to
your statement I want and on the reverse
side of the statement I want there is
the statement I don't have and I
need and similar things please give me
if you you pray
to maybe God maybe you pray to Jesus
maybe you pray to Buddha they do that in
Buddhist countries maybe you pray to a
saint or whatever it is or you pray to
the universe and say please universe
please give me this please give me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works it could be accidentally who knows
but usually uh that greatly diminishes
your power of manifestation because it
the man manifestation practice arises
out of a state of lack or neediness so
there's no powerful manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple state ment by Jesus and
that
encapsulates all the
books that have been written on
manifestation and will ever be written
on manifestation it's just one simple
sentence it says when you pray for
something believe that
you that it has been given or that you
already have it and then then you will
receive it so the important thing is he
doesn't say believe that you will
receive it he says believe that you have
received it so there the secret is
hiding in that statement believe that
you have received it and the moment you
watch the screen whether it's television
or what screen you might have noticed
that the your own your so-called own
thought processes come to a stop so to
some extent you're free of the self this
is why people sometimes find watching
television relaxing ing say okay I just
need to relax now just turn it
on by this they mean while they watch
the television screen they are not
burdened by their self induced thought
processes what they do however they
replace the their own Thoughts with the
collective thoughts so they just you're
in a state you're not in a state of
thoughtless awareness when you watch
television or you watch something on the
screen you absorb the thoughts from
there into your mind and you you link
into so it for people often in a state
of semi or hypnosis when they watch and
it kind of paralyzes you can also happen
with a screen with television already
started of course um don't know when
whenever tell 60 years ago whenever
television started and you
go and so your mind is just absorbing
whatever is playing it's the TV mind
which is receiving stuff from where
where it comes from is going into your
mind and you become
a no longer thinking your own thoughts
occasionally your mind you say oh this
guy is so stupid and then you're
watching
again and then another thought why am I
watching this
rubbish
half an hour
later this is so
awful but you can't you can't can't turn
it off here's the here's the
remote let's let's just try one more
Channel there might be something else
there oh no that's stupid try one
more this is this is how an addict
behaves
and the device is even more addictive
you because you carry them with
you and uh you have to admit you may
have to admit that you there's an
addiction in you not everybody here but
quite a few it would be almost normal to
feel this draw towards it and you use it
even when you don't need to use it it
that's the amazing thing when you're
standing at the
elevator
waiting another person is standing next
to you and he or she is pulling out the
phone and then you pull out yours you
don't know
why or anywhere you in a you order
waiting you're ordering a tea or coffee
somewhere and you're standing in line
and if you look around there's almost
nobody and probably no nobody who is not
looking at this little
thing this is
scary zombie like the
feeling first of all needs to be
acknowledged and
accepted uh you can't start with letting
go so you have to start with
acknowledging
it and accepting that it's there there
because it's part of what is the isness
of the present moment whether it's an
external thing or an inner thing it is
it is what
is and to deny or to argue with what is
creates
suffering
so you acknowledge you accept that it's
there
then how much time time you
need to be with
it depends various from person to person
and what what kind of a feeling it is
and so
[Music]
on and then the question arises what is
the link between that feeling and your
thought
processes
the person needs to to find
out whether the thought
[Music]
processes keep that feeling alive
continuously whether they renew by
playing out for example a past scenario
in their
minds by
Reviving memories from the past by
dwelling on certain narratives that are
painful repeating them in their
minds that gives Renewed Energy to the
feeling MH so the first the most
important thing is to be aware of both
levels what's the level of my thinking
how does that contribute to the
perpetuation of what I
feel and so you also then acknowledge
that oh the these are the habitual
thought patterns that go through my mind
in relation to the
feelings and then the you would begin to
realize
that the Letting Go the most important
step in letting go of feelings is to cut
the link between your thinking and what
you're feeling how do you do that you do
it
by by being aware of your thinking and
realizing that
that thinking is pain it feeds the old
feeling and the narrative whatever it is
is a painful
narrative and you realize that you've
been keeping it alive for some
years and you when you there's some
enough awareness you realize that it has
no
purpose except to make you unhappy and
perpet uate that feeling the
da or
Consciousness in its pure
form is pure no
form before it becomes something before
it
becomes the
thought or
words so right
now you're aware
of sense perceptions because you can
still see
me you're aware of the
words but more
importantly you are
aware that you are aware you know
yourself as
this aware presence
space without that space that aware
space you would there would be no sense
perception it is the
light of
Consciousness in which all the objects
of Consciousness are
perceived most people are not aware of
themselves as
Consciousness they're only aware of the
object that arise in
Consciousness and their sense of
identity
also their sense of who they
are
ultimately is an object that arises in
their
[Music]
Consciousness that's
me this is my story me and my story my
identity I am this and that and that and
all those things together that's
me but they all thought forms or
emotional forms that arise in
Consciousness they are an object in
Consciousness and this object in
consciousness for most
people is the found Foundation of their
sense of
identity but that unfortunately is a an
enormous
limitation and ultimately a
misperception of who they actually
are most people's sense of identity
therefore is based on a misperception
ception because who you truly are is not
an object in
Consciousness that's Emeral it it it is
here for a while then it
evaporates who you truly
are is the space of Consciousness
itself and so you become aware of an
[Music]
underlying presence just to use a
word and a an a
wakefulness a certain
alertness a
Stillness but not a Stillness that is
asleep an alert
Stillness
that's the
realization of
[Music]
consciousness of
yourself as Consciousness to practice
self-observation
is
implies that there is enough presence or
awareness in you from where you can self
observe and in almost all of you there
there is maybe not all the
time but there is there is enough to
have brought you here and that is quite
a bit so is there enough presence in you
so that you can self observe your own
motivations your own thought structures
what are the habitual thoughts that I
think so that you are not drawn
continuously into every thought that
comes and follow it where it wants to
take you one little thought comes in
about your your life oh and then another
thought and you follow it
oh oh
No and then before you know it you more
thoughts come in than other conflicting
thoughts and no no that's not how it is
yes it is
no I can't take anymore and you believe
in that thought too that you can't take
[Music]
anymore
so the ability to to observe
non-judgmentally what goes on inside you
there is awareness there needs to be
awareness so that is
self knowledge is there some type of
discipline that is needed to be
successful with conscious manifestation
if so can you describe what the
discipline is that is
needed
[Music]
well basically I have already described
the discipline that's needed for in your
daily life to be a to be aware of
yourself and of your own State of
Consciousness
uh also an important factor perhaps that
is implied in what we've been saying but
it's worth pointing it
out
explicitly is the importance
of what is conventionally
called
gratitude but there could be other words
gratitude uh is a very powerful
transformational tool and also one of
the most powerful tools for
manifesting better things in your
life now what does that mean the
Gratitude is to to a
knowledge the good in your life
now and you it's
surprising how many people don't do
that who can only see the bad in their
lives or only complain but it's
extremely powerful to acknowledge the
good that's in your life
now yeah there may be one or two
people being with us here
there who perhaps are stuck somewhere in
a room and can't get out because of
physical disability or they may be in
prison and they say what can I do what
can we do we can't get out into
nature well you need to remember that
your body also is nature so you can
start there every time you take a
breath that's nature nature is breathing
the air that you're breathing is
nature the very fact of breathing is a
natural
process it's not
Choice it's done for you it's not so
much that you breathe although we say I
breathe but you're not the body breathes
so it's a natural thing that happens you
wouldn't say I'm beating my heart you
don't do that but that's the same thing
the body does it it's a natural process
for some reason we say I'm breathing
because breathing is semi
voluntary you can stop it for a
while but not for that long because if
you stop it for too long nature takes
over and they
go so nature takes says nature you live
with nature with your body so even if
you can't get out you can start by being
aware of that level of
yourself the the physical
level the natural part of who you are
the body and not just by saying okay I'm
looking at my hands or my feet not just
the physic not the external image of the
body but you can go into the body with
your
attention and that's you're in nature
even if you're in a present cell you can
do
that and even if there's no opportunity
you might be in an office Block in
Manhattan and you look out of the window
and all you have is maybe a little bit
of Sky okay there's a little bit of
nature there you can look at that but
you have more nature than that in
yourself so as you sat in your office
wherever it
is go within first be conscious that
breathing is
happening the body is
breathing be conscious also of the the
preciousness of the air it's such a
precious
substance so to acknowledge that is
actually part of what sometimes is
called to to live in a state
of
gratitude now some people say what can I
be grateful for there's nothing in my
life that I can be grateful for well are
you breathing
yes well you start there be aware of
the conceptualizing your
life and
allowing an unhappy
story in your
head to make you
unhappy people think they're unhappy
because of the circumstances of their
lives in most cases they're
unhappy because
of what they're telling themselves or
what the mind is saying
about what's going on around you and has
happened will
happen so that's a it's a
suffering the origin of suffering to a
large extent is there and even in
extreme situations having lost your home
for
example not knowing where to
live you even there it
applies you do not in the face of a
challenge if you are
present you don't convert the challenge
into
suffering you just be with what
is and you start experimenting with
little things in your life that cause
you
irritation or a little bit of anger or
some
impatience let situations that are very
common every
day and you look at the situation you
become aware suddenly that there's
irritation arising or anger
arising and you become aware that it
does doesn't actually feel very good and
the body knows it doesn't feel good the
body doesn't like
it there's irritation arising and you
think it's because of what's going on
but if you look more closely think now
is this situation causing this or is
what I'm saying about it causing this
what my mind the commentary of my
mind and in most cases you will find
it's the mental commentary that you had
been identified with that causes the
unhappiness and then you say let's
experiment with removing the commentary
how would I experience this situation if
I did not ADD the mental baggage to
it so in other words you're just now
with the isness of this
moment without any thing mental stuff
added being added to it that says this
should not be happening I don't want to
be here and many other
things
suddenly you're
fine a minute
ago you were extremely irritated and
angry and you you couldn't differentiate
between the
circumstances external circumstan of
your life and the inner commentary about
the circumstances and and this is the
essence of
unconsciousness unable to differentiate
between the circumstances and the
commentary so the circumstances and the
commentary become single is are
experienced as a single
phenomenon and then when you suddenly
you can
separate this is the isness of this
moment and it is as it
is enormous power is suddenly arising in
you which is the power of the present
moment which is The Power Of
unconditioned Consciousness also the
power of dealing with a situation if
there's something that you need to do
suddenly right action as the Buddha
calls it right action happens or
non-action if action is not possible
then right surrender
happens but you allow this moment to be
as it is
without but what does it mean means you
don't add unnecessary mental baggage to
it that argues with the isness of this
moment usually happiness exists as part
of the play of opposites you experience
the happiness because something makes
you happy and then that thing that made
you happy either leaves you or the very
thing that made you happy suddenly makes
you
unhappy
marriage for
[Music]
example or a
relationship before you start living
together you're happy when you start
living together you
unhappy so what is if it's not happy
what are we talking about
the there's
a
if
you let go of thinking and remain as the
awareness then there is in that that
awareness emanates a certain peace
alive
peace Joy peace a
peaceful joyful sense of
aliveness inner peace maybe a better
word than happiness but one would have
to add to it it's an alive piece it's
not the piece of uh having deadened
yourself to
emotions or anything like that it's an
alive intensely alive peace you can
sense
it even if it's only just a glimpse
right
now surrender
thought and of
course right now if you're not thinking
about the problems of your life there
are no problems in this moment there's
only a sense of beingness or
liveness and that is the connectedness
with
being and so you transcend the opposite
sit between happiness and unhappiness if
you're unable to enjoy what you're
doing then it's time to move to another
job but you have to look to see whether
your inability to enjoy the job you're
doing
now has something to do with the
particular job you're doing or has more
to
do with with your inability to enjoy the
present
moment in which case the next object you
find you will also not
enjoy so if you can't enjoy your
job either one of these is true either
there is something for you to change
there's something inherently not right
anymore with this particular job does no
longer corresponds to
what to who you are or your State of
Consciousness
or you cannot enjoy your job because you
haven't learned
yet to be present enough to enjoy what
you are doing now and you always
think oh the next one is going to be
much
[Music]
better and if you don't know which one
it is of those
two you may have to get another job and
then see
if you can enjoy that
one many jobs that the mind tells you
cannot be
enjoyed actually can be
enjoyed also the mind telling you if you
enjoy this job that you do you really
don't want this job to be permanent and
if the mind tells you no if I enjoy this
job I'll be stuck with it for the rest
of my life and I don't want to be stuck
with it let's say you you you got
to you got a job
working
[Music]
uh working in a diner as a waiter or
waitress but you really want to get your
job as an actress or you really want to
be a writer you really want to
be uh whatever you want to be a
senator
uh successor of Donald Trump whatever
your mind
says and so the mind says like I'm not
going to enjoy this job because I really
want to be somewhere else and if I enjoy
it then I'll really be
stuck but you may find that the opposite
is the case if you it it is freeing to
enjoy what you are doing even if it's
not something that you would want to do
for the rest of your life all you have
to do is enjoy the present
moment your energy field then
shifts and when this energy field energy
field shifts you become open to life
only if you no longer resist life you
cannot be open to
life the greater Consciousness coming
through you if you resist life and you
resist life if
you resist or resent the present moment
that's where life is so the shift
happens you need to be in the state of
alignment with the present moment no
matter what activity you are doing in
the present moment and if you absolutely
cannot be in alignment with the present
moment you need to walk out I would love
to hear your thoughts on your definition
of the Law of Attraction but also maybe
the three habits that you see people
doing the most that hurt them from
attracting effortlessly using the law
attraction right well the main uh
mistake perhaps that people make is uh
not coming from a place of fullness but
coming from a place of
neediness and uh and putting too much
attention on on what
is the undesirable conditions that they
want to get rid of but but but mentally
almost continuously focusing on the
undesired
condition like not enough money for
example which is a problem for many
people uh so so let's use let's use
money for example then the Law of
Attraction with money how could we
attract more wealth or financial
abundance in our life using the Law of
Attraction yeah well first of all is the
acknowledgment of abundance that is
already here and now
and not and not focusing on the lack of
abundance that is here now which you
could find by thinking about it but to
actually focus on where is the abundance
that I can find here and now and that is
all around you it is in nature when you
look at the the abundance of nature the
Abundant the multiplicity of life forms
The Wonder of nature uh the abundance of
even even or let's say you're in a city
uh you can look at uh appreciate all the
things that you see uh around you you
don't need to necessarily own it or buy
it just appreciate it and so this first
the
appreciation of the goodness of life
that is always all around you even if
you have no money there's still the
goodness of life is all around you you
see it all around you the
sunshine I mean the sun is the
ultimate symbol of abundance because it
gives energy of itself almost Eternal I
mean eventually the sun will die but as
far as we are concerned it's virtually
Eternal it it pours out energy
continuously and this uh at some point
we will realize that even on the level
of energy the universe is infinitely
abundant so we we will no longer
need things that we're using now fossil
Fu and those things we have access to
other forms of energy that are more
helpful but right the abundance the
abundance is all around you let's say
you walk your past in the city you're
walking past this lower shop and you
look at wow such beauty
appreciation even to seeing a beautiful
man or woman or nice or or a beautiful
car oh I love it not why don't I have
that car why does he have that car it's
all
egoic much narratives that make you
unhappy to appreciate no nature of
course is very powerful and then you to
appreciate the aliveness in your body
that you're breathing and you can
actually feel that the the your body but
many people can't feel that I call it
the inner body awareness
you feel that your that every cell of
your body is pervaded with a sense of
aliveness energy and you can feel that
that is abundance so there's abundance
of Life all around you there's there's
you can feel the life within you also
and so we could some people call it
gratitude I call it more appreciation
the appreciation of the abundance of
life that is always around you that's a
wonderful starting point
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hasht believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Micha a singer motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there that's not fun is
it right let say you're going to give a
talk in your class all right lot of
people the Mind gives a little trouble
before that doesn't it oh my God what if
I forget my lines does anybody's mind
ever do that to them doesn't that help
you perform better no it doesn't